I cannot be silent through the tears
that keep on coming the dam has been
broken There's No Going Back
they are alarming insights into the
lives of head teachers and the
devastating impact an ofsted inspection
can have the sleepless nights the
endless crying the feeling of being a
failure
the suicide of school leader Ruth Perry
triggering painful memories for many and
he was really struggling indeed Simon
kidwell's School in Cheshire was
inspected last month his eighth one as a
head teacher yet it still triggered his
insomnia I think it's the intensity of
the process I think it's the adrenaline
because it's very very high stakes I
think if I was to get an adequate
judgment I'd be absolutely bereft and I
don't know if I could continue in
education
Ruth Perry's family say she felt the
same way the head teacher took her own
life in January after an inspection that
would downgrade her school in Reading
from outstanding to inadequate but this
tragedy is by no means an isolated case
in the last 25 years there have been at
least 10 teachers who have taken their
own life where the stress of an ofsted
inspection has been cited in the
coroner's report as a factor and for
many in the sector the fear is there
will be more if nothing changes
so far ofsted's resisted calls to scrap
the single word judgments but those
calls for reform are only getting louder
reducing it to one single grade is is
nonsense I mean there's ample research
out there when we used to go and um
grade lessons that you may as well you
may as well just toss a coin
in terms of getting it accurate hello
yes Andrew here from Andrew Morris quit
is an ofsted inspector in 2015. he
claims teams would go into schools with
their minds made up already and would
change evidence to fit their
predetermined rating I can think of a
number of times a conversation has been
had with me that you know you might want
to go and rethink what you put in that
evidence form that doesn't reconcile
with with what your other colleagues are
seeing and that's not particularly
helpful in terms of us trying to get
through to the overall final grade so I
felt you know very uncomfortable with
that
in a statement ofsted said our
inspections are first and foremost for
children and their parents we always
want inspections to be constructive and
collaborative and in the vast majority
of cases School leaders agree that they
are
but many clearly feel this is a fatal
lesson that hasn't been learned either
Bennett Sky News Cheshire